Christmas Christmas I love Christmas
reason of best time of the year if I
could somehow they love to Christmas I
would and then I would eat it to consume
all its wholesome holiday juices I love
it that much I love the snow
I love the presents I love the
decorations I even love thee to Max's
little novelty items that burn money
like a Yuletide fire but most of all I
love but most of all I love the
Christmas specials the movies the shows
the classic shorts I love them all
hello I'm the Nostalgia Christmas aye
Christmas so Christmas Christmas it's
the most wonderful time of the
[Applause]
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembered so you don't have to
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to Merry
Christmas
I know a lot of you expect they need to
have some sort of big explosion of joy
and cheer like I do all the other years
but a lot of people have been saying
that was kind of scary and not really
keeping in the Christmas spirit so to
keep me more relaxed I have a chill pill
patch so it'll keep you completely under
control so this year things are going to
be a bit more traditional we have a
fireplace decorations we even have snow
I have no idea how that's possible
why hello Malcolm and Tamara got some
cookies and eggnog for this holiday
season
yes to relax us in this time of this
isn't right huh this is Christmas you
should be able to celebrate it however
you want to
sorry Tamara but I don't want to scare
the sweet people at home with my
disturbing obsession I want to be
relaxed soothing marketable that's what
people like yeah you weren't here the
previous years
trust me this is for the best this isn't
right
[Music]
and seeing how we are having a much more
calm and subdued Christmas we're gonna
celebrate with a traditional calm subdue
Christmas special here's a little ditty
I like to call grandma got run over by a
reindeer I hope you enjoyed that and I'm
so sorry I couldn't have my traditional
over-the-top reaction to Christmas this
year but like every element of our media
says it should be calm relaxing soothing
just a little bit silly just like
grandma got run over by a reindeer so
from all of us to you I wish you a very
Merry Christmas
critic this isn't right you shouldn't
refresh yourself during the holidays you
don't know what you're doing you should
be able to express yourself however you
want here must stop putting your freak
sorry what have you done Malcolm no one
should have to hold back their feelings
on Christmas Christmas is about love
beauty and the acceptance of your
[Music]
I'm full of Christmas semen I don't know
what it is but it's hot it's like F in
sarcasm inside an oatmeal cookie shot
and when I put my Santa hat on and it's
a needle full of Christmas kaliya
coating my house in freely shit Disney
trademark intellectual property cause
it's no wig shopping fucking Christmas
the lights of my fuckin house a fuckin
bet you crazy about Christmas
fucking Christmas
ladies and gentlemen Jesus Christ of the
electric guitar
[Applause]
you want dynamic diamond side
I'll buy all things are they green
accumulating thousands of dentro cannot
Bhutan ruin my life making it the best
Christmas yet don't play those Christmas
carols until like usually with Christmas
cheer
it'll scare the shit out of you but it's
only getting bigger every year does it
snow we gonna shop
to scare the shit out of because I'm
fucking batshit crazy about Christmas
the trade and hot chocolates and my skin
is red and the teal stem appeals and
appeals in the Steel's embassy keep it
longer make a stronger nothing song here
getting I feeling wire I misfire I'm a
buyer right
by the way the scenes available on our
team
I want to smash it open gold and a
surgeon's control don't ever fucking do
that again I'm sorry but he has a
sickness they're gonna be cured by
repression and tranquilizers
yes fucking scary it's snowing you know
I love shopping and I farfel farfel
farfel King loved Christmas enough to
build tranquilizer immunity I must be
fucking batshit wait a minute What did
he say I'll kill anyone not celebrating
with me your assistant defeating my
insanity does it's no big so what the
star atop the tree you find the lucky TV
we're going on
was coming over
boy that did feel good thanks so much
you guys hey Jesus
[Music]
ah the first day of December I'm so
excited I decided to announce that date
to myself run white what what's going on
there's no time to explain
[Music]
[Applause]
finally did it let my love of Christmas
destroy the world
the state will come hey I got a review
to do it's Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
as mayor of the universe an award CC
cuckoo clocks as the biggest lover of
Christmas in all the galaxies well done
with this holiday is unrivaled by anyone
for this award I'm very flattered by it
it is so wonderful to know that no one
in the entire solar system
anywhere up plus Christmas as much as I
what was that what it sounds like the
light Barrett being broken and the speed
of time being walked and every
conceivable ozone layer being shattered
I win
[Music]
my god I didn't think you needed to
travel to another dimension to prove
your love of Christmas well this is said
to be the dimension that loves Christmas
the most and I had to let my love for
this holiday destroy them all
nobody loves Christmas more than me
today my god we may have missed one
the west of the Christmas it has to be
here there's only one way to defeat it
let's DEXA my ass
[Music]
my god it's the Christmas Eve queen my
god it's doubled inside
oh my god I thought this was gonna be a
challenge my god she's gonna breathe
presence on us Yuletide chainsaws clever
girl
she's spitting gifts back bullet tennis
genius bitch it's just I wanted that she
could pose so small no she's gonna
finish this off with a holiday
flamethrower just like on my Amazon
wishlist me too
baby you messed with the wrong holiday
[Applause]
[Music]
I think we should stop trying to top
ourselves every year with Christmas
greetings getting a little out of
Hampton mm-hmm I think nothing was
pregnant so we get to live with that
you